alors les conditions de travail des
policiers en baisse de 37 % du budget
équipements entre 2005 et 2012
on a parlé également de nombre de
suicides c'est terrible dans la police
50 suicides en 2018 et 28 d'intuit déjà
depuis le début de l'année 2019 est ce
que vous comprenez ce ras-le-bol des
policiers face notamment aux baisses de
budget d'équipement et puis même aussi
parfois quand comme ils le disent là
cette terreur qui peuvent avoir c'est le
fait qu'ils sont aussi des hommes
d'action
alors quand je vois ce reportage et ses
conditions inhumaines dans lesquelles
travaillent les policiers franchement
moi j'ai le coeur qui se soulève alors
je pense que ce ras-le-bol peut
s'expliquer par plusieurs dizaines de
raisons mais moi j'en retiendrai que
deux après les attentats de 2015 à
charlie hebdo on s'en souvient les
policiers étaient considérés comme des
héros est véritable voilà des des
sauveurs de la nation tout le monde
voulait devenir policier à ce moment là
aujourd'hui
l'époque a bien changé ils sont
considérés comme des pestiférés
notamment à cause de certaines personnes
qui est volé les font passer pour des
bourreaux notamment avec des vidéos sur
les réseaux sociaux et la deuxième
raison est bien simple le manque de
moyens est fixé ce manque de moyens
malheureusement qui font que face à une
politique du chiffre c'est intenable et
à 21 millions d'heures supplémentaires
qui n'ont pas été payés pour récupérer
donc c'est un scandale et c'est ce qui
pousse justement à ces chiffres de
suicides qui sont scandale jimmy je vous
entendez dire à votre camarade là tu vas
trop loin
il ay dina là je suis désolé bien là tu
dis un peu n'importe quoi et tu mélanges
tout est finalisé ac
là on parle des conditions dans laquelle
ils travaillent le fait que leurs heures
supplémentaires ne soient pas payés le
fait qu'il n'ait pas de matériel le fait
qu'ils travaillent dans des
commissariats vétuste avec des
ordinateurs qui marchent pas des
voitures qui sont peut-être pas chine
avait eu un d'ailleurs il y avait une
campagne sur les réseaux sociaux où ils
ont filmé leur commissariat dans avec
des situations totalement vétustes et ça
qui est entièrement dramatique et on
peut pas d'un autre côté fermé les yeux
sur d'éventuelles violences policières
des erreurs mais on peut appeler ça
comme on veut ce sont deux choses
différentes
et ce n'est pas parce qu'ils travaillent
dans des conditions difficiles qu'il
faut justifier les violences et la même
façon ce n'est pas parce qu'ils
travaillent dans des conditions
difficiles qu'il faudrait se dire oh là
là il faut les mettre à l'abri non quand
on est policier
on sait pourquoi on s'engage c'est à
dire qu'on va dans la bagarre la
castagne l'on sait très bien que ça lui
faisait exactement signeront au métier
même façon lorsqu'on soldats ou pompiers
on s'engage on sait très bien qu'il peut
avoir des débordements et des problèmes
en ne mélangeons pas tout et nos dîners
arrêtons de dire les vidéos sur les
réseaux sociaux mais les et drame et
j'en viens maintenant mais je suis
désolé c'est lié jimmy et tu ne peux pas
deux
non on peut pas fermer les yeux sur les
violences policières tu as certainement
raison mais le problème c'est que les
gens n'ont pas forcément l'intelligence
de faire la différence entre tous les
policiers et certains policiers qui
effectivement se rendre coupables de
violences policières donc je suis désolé
ça participe aussi à ce ras-le-bol
aujourd'hui les policiers on les voit
comme des casseurs de manifestants or
pour la très grande majorité d'entre eux
ce n'est pas le cas donc voilà je suis
là il voit pas du tout mais caroline
dans le piège que tu en train de décrire
cette fois qui met tous les précédents
le même sac moi je sais pas où tu as vu
que les policiers n'étaient pas
aujourd'hui considérés comme des héros
de la nation ils sont considérés comme
des héros de la nation c'est parfois de
son penser et on a reçu ici des femmes
de policiers qui venaient témoigner
parce qu'elle avait écrit un avis là
dessus et elle le disait elle-même elles
disent y'a des vagues c'est à dire que
on sait que lorsqu'il ya par exemple une
vague d'attentats et qu'on a entre
guillemets besoin d'un policier on les
porte aux nues et que ben il ya un
mouvement de ressac et puis et que ce
moment là effectivement il ya une petite
défiance et de certains de et sur les
policiers avaient la fin c'est une
défiance est aussi un respect de
l'autorité et encore heureux que ça
existe maintenant pour ce qui est
vraiment de ce qu'on a vu un reportage
qu'ils s'étonnent d'arriver dans une
rixe dans une bagarre
là je dis non parce que j'aime moi
tomassi ils sont étonnés et tout le
roman qu'il ne s'attendait pas à être
dans des conditions telles et notamment
la loi us open il ya eu le reportage
aussi de la policière qui est à bout de
nerfs parce que elle considère qu' elle
a trop de travail et qu'il ya trop de
violence bah oui c'est sûr qu'on n'est
pas au pays des bisounours donc quand on
s'engage dans l'intro vivre mais demain
mais c'est pas pour enfiler des perles
et et trouvé que le monde est jolie qui
n'est que le monde qui nous entoure l au
lycée c'est très compliqué donc vous
maudissent à qui ils ont signé pour ils
ont signé pour vous nous sommes d'accord
mais c'est dingue on en a pas reçues les
mêmes sujets madame beinheim c'est pas
possible j'ai l'impression d'avoir vu un
sujet totalement différent de celui de
damien du caroline je suis désolé ce
n'est pas parce qu'ils savent thème
mythes et rites un perdant c'est pas
parce qu'ils savent ce dans quoi ils
s'engagent en signant pour la police
qu'ils doivent travailler dans des
conditions si inqualifiable suis désolé
quand on voit la pauvre policière qui a
ses photos avec les remontées d'égouts
dans le temps dans les vestiaires on est
des femmes quand même valérie gens ne
vous dire allez allez avec une odeur de
merde pour rentrer chez soi c'est pas
possible
ils sont là à sauver des inconnus tous
les jours ils sont là pour la patrie il
ya un moment où la patrie les a laissés
tomber
et toi d'amiante eu comme d'habitude
soit un démago et qui mélangent pas
démago je suis désolé
les tables les employeurs c'est ça je
mets absolument c'est l'état qui est
fautif est pas une faille pagnon palais
nous ce que vous en pensez avec le
hashtag c'est que des lt de ce
ras-le-bol des policiers de cette
situation avec un jeu le rappel des
chiffres assez alarmant quand même 36 %
du budget d'équipement entre 2005 et
2012 qui en baisse et 50 suicides dans
la police en 2018 et déjà 28 depuis le
début de l'année 2019